we continue to follow some of the most
important races that could determine who
controls what for the next two years one
such race is the Georgia Senate race
where incumbent Democratic senator
Rafael Warnock is trying to beat off an
attack from former football player
Herschel Walker as you know Herschel
Walker can barely speak he certainly
seems unable to think he's not able to
explain his position coherently on any
issue he appeared over the weekend with
Fox News Trump brown noser Maria
Bartiromo and it is truly frightening
that this could be one of 100 members of
the U.S Senate being a completely
incoherent
individual which we have become
accustomed to but picking up on words
he's hearing elsewhere
without any idea how to use them here
claiming that they are bringing pronouns
to the military right now he's called
all men and women in blue Thugs and
bullets they bringing pronouns into our
military but yet they're saying it's the
Republican's fault yeah they're bringing
pronouns to the military I hate to break
it to your Herschel they're using verbs
they're using nouns they're using
adverbs it's they're even using
prepositional phrases in the military he
hears something that sounds like what
he's supposed to be saying and he
repeats it and he has no clue what he is
talking about in another moment during
this interview of all the different
threats to the United States that we're
dealing with right now
he says the real threat is that Raphael
Warnock will vote against the Keystone
Pipeline feeling now 48 hours away
well I feel I feel pretty good you know
when you have a president talking about
the biggest threat to the market city
has seen to be electing a republican but
I want everyone out that is listening to
me the biggest threat to democracy is to
have him at the White House and the
biggest threat to democracy is to have
someone guys I mean listen I it is it
nitpicky that he can't say democracy
that he called it democracy three times
during this like is that you know you
you point these things out and these
right Wingers go David that's racist I I
thought you were the ones who said we
were racist when we see race I'm not
mentioning the guy's race I'm telling
you he can't speak or think
and now Republic oh you David what huh
the guy's completely incoherent like
Senator why not to vote against our
Keystone Pipeline oh God put us in an
international threat uh I think right
now that's a that's a threat and it puts
us in a threat when Warnock votes
against Keystone
explain that to me
uh it's a security threat with going to
our enemies to ask for energy that's a
threat that's a biggest threat to the
market City there and also because men
and women sports which he voted for that
right that's another big threat to the
country men in women's sports an issue
affecting
zero point what 0.05 I mean come on guys
and Maria Bartiromo enables it they all
enable it by pretending this is normal
biggest threat to democracy is how the
people the Democrats right now leading
this country because they seem to be
taking this country in the wrong
direction yeah give me the indicators
Herschel give me the specific indicators
by which you could make that case so
here's the good news and the bad news
and they're both the same anybody could
win this race I know that many of you
were very worried because of this Gap
that was closed by Herschel Walker
which now has Herschel Walker ahead by
half a point on average I'm going to be
very direct and Frank with all of you
who the hell cares what the polls say
right now many people writing to me
saying David A lot of these polls are
right-wing biased Remington is a
right-wing poll as an example Remington
has Walker plus four here's the way to
think about it this thing is tied okay
some of the specific polls are literally
a tie like the recent Marist poll even
if you average all the polls including
the supposed right-wing polls
it's half a point that separates these
two
anybody can win if you believe that the
polls are biased towards Walker but that
early voter turnout favors uh Warnock
and but just go and vote if you vote in
Georgia if you believe Walker's really
winning then go and vote and make it so
that his margin shrinks by one vote
all we have to do is go and vote and we
will very soon know whether one of the
most humiliating realities about the
Senate will become a reality or whether
we can avoid complete and total disaster
you've heard me talk about the accounts
we've had hacked it's a horrible
experience it can happen to anyone look
up the stats if it hasn't happened to
you yet it may at some point protecting
yourself against scammers online can get
complicated our sponsor Aura is the
all-in-one solution that I now use to
keep accounts safe Aura scans the dark
web for your personal info emails
passwords Social Security numbers
immediately alerts you if anything is
found helps you fix the problem you also
get alerts about suspicious credit
inquiries or automatically request the
removal of your information from search
engines and data broker sites and Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware with its state-of-the-art
antivirus and Aura also helps you manage
what your kids can do on their devices
with very simple easy to use parental
device controls you can try or a free
for two weeks at aura.com Pacman your
login credentials might already be
floating around it takes only a few
seconds on Aura to figure that out and
think of all of the other useful things
you'll discover during the two-week
trial the link is down below